It's peak pollination season, and my business is scaling fast. To keep the nectar flowing, I need a phone plan with top priority data speeds. That's why I chose Google Fi Wireless. My connections stay strong even when the hive is buzzing. Plus, unlimited plans started $35 a month. Now that's a deal that doesn't stay. Explore Google Fi Wireless plans today. Plus taxes and government fees.
现在是授粉高峰期，我的生意规模正在迅速扩大。为了保持花蜜源源不断，我需要一个拥有最高优先级数据速度的手机套餐。这就是我选择 Google Fi Wireless 的原因。即使在蜂巢最繁忙的时候，我的连接依然保持强劲。此外，无限流量套餐每月仅需 35 美元起。这可是一个不会一直有的优惠。立即探索 Google Fi Wireless 套餐吧。另需缴纳税费和政府费用。
Google Fi Wireless is not subject to data traffic deprioritization during times of high network usage. of us, the movies offer us our earliest lessons in love. From meat cutes and coffee shops to musical serenades to dramatic airport chase scenes, romantic comedies have long shaped our expectations about what love and romance might or ought to look like. But how much do rom-coms get right about relationships and how much do they get wrong? And why are these types of movies often so emotionally satisfying. Today we're going to talk to two psychologists who study the science of attraction, commitment, and love about the real life lessons we can take from on-screen love stories.
Google Fi Wireless 在网络高负载时段不会受到数据流量降速的影响。对我们来说，电影提供了我们最早的爱情启蒙。从浪漫邂逅和咖啡馆相遇，到音乐小夜曲，再到戏剧性的机场追逐戏，浪漫喜剧长期以来塑造了我们对爱情和浪漫应该是什么样子的期望。但是，浪漫喜剧在人际关系方面有多少是正确的，又有多少是错误的呢？为什么这类电影往往在情感上如此令人满足？今天，我们将与两位研究吸引力、承诺和爱情科学的心理学家探讨我们可以从银幕爱情故事中汲取的现实生活经验。
So what are the biggest dating and relationship myths that movies perpetuate? And conversely, what do they get right? How does pop culture shape society's ideas about love and relationships? And how well do your favorite character's love stories hold up when analyzed through the reductive lens of science. Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. We have two guests today. First is Dr. Paul Eastwick, a professor of psychology at the University of California Davis, where he runs the attraction and relationships research lab. He studies how people initiate romantic relationships and the psychological mechanisms that help partners remain
那么，电影中延续的最大约会和关系误区是什么？反过来说，它们又有哪些是正确的？流行文化如何塑造社会对爱情和关系的看法？当你通过科学的还原视角来分析你最喜欢的角色的爱情故事时，它们经得起推敲吗？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。今天我们有两位嘉宾。第一位是加州大学戴维斯分校的心理学教授保罗·伊斯特威克博士，他在那里负责吸引力与关系研究实验室。他研究人们如何开启浪漫关系，以及帮助伴侣保持
committed and attached. He's the author of more than 80 scientific papers and is working on a book entitled Bonded by Evolution set to be published in 2026. Next is Dr. Eli Finkel, a social psychologist at Northwestern University where he has appointments in the psychology department and the Kellogg School of Management. He studies romantic relationships and American politics and is author of the best-selling book, The All-or-Nothing Marriage, How the Best Marriages Work. Dr. Finkel and Eastwood are co-hosts of the podcast, Love Factually, which employs the science of relationships to examine popular romantic comedies and dramas.
承诺和依恋的心理机制。他撰写了 80 多篇科学论文，目前正在撰写一本名为《进化纽带》（Bonded by Evolution）的书，预计于 2026 年出版。接下来是西北大学的社会心理学家伊莱·芬克尔博士，他在心理学系和凯洛格管理学院任职。他研究浪漫关系和美国政治，是畅销书《全或无的婚姻：最好的婚姻是如何运作的》（The All-or-Nothing Marriage, How the Best Marriages Work）的作者。芬克尔博士和伊斯特威克博士是播客《事实上的爱情》（Love Factually）的联合主持人，该播客运用关系科学来审视流行的浪漫喜剧和剧情片。
The podcast examines what these movies get right and wrong compared with how relationships work in the real world. Dr. Eastwick, Dr. Finkel, thank you for joining me today. Thanks so much for having us, Kim. Thank you. Let's start by talking about how this podcast came about. How did you two scientists get the idea to do a podcast podcast together about romantic comedies and what was your goal when you started it?
该播客审视了这些电影与现实世界中关系运作方式相比，哪些是正确的，哪些是错误的。伊斯特威克博士、芬克尔博士，感谢你们今天加入我的节目。非常感谢邀请我们，金。谢谢。让我们从这个播客是如何产生的开始谈起。你们两位科学家是如何想到一起做一个关于浪漫喜剧的播客的？你们开始做这个播客时的目标是什么？
We talk about movies and psychology all the time. We've been doing research together for literally decades. And then on the side, we had this interest in film. And we realized that we could combine these interests into a podcast that uses relationship science to evaluate the themes that romantic films send into our culture. And we thought it was a great opportunity, almost like a Trojan horse, for getting people who are interested in relationships, interested in movies to learn a little bit about the science along the way. Who is your target audience? And do you know, are you reaching it? You know, I'd like to think that we are. I mean, what I think about with any kind of outreach efforts is that In psychology, there are so many people out there who have, I think, good ideas about the way
我们一直在谈论电影和心理学。我们在一起做研究已经有几十年了。业余时间，我们对电影也很感兴趣。我们意识到可以将这些兴趣结合起来，做一个播客，利用关系科学来评估浪漫电影传达给我们的文化主题。我们认为这是一个绝佳的机会，就像“特洛伊木马”一样，让那些对人际关系感兴趣、对电影感兴趣的人在观看的同时也能学到一点科学知识。你们的目标受众是谁？你们知道你们是否触达了他们吗？你知道，我愿意认为我们做到了。我的意思是，对于任何形式的推广工作，我的想法是，在心理学领域，有很多人对
the human mind works, the way that people relate to each other. But they don't certainly have the scientific backing to know that there's support for some of these things and not for other things. And so I think about our job is like, look, we're trying to give people a little bit of a foundation, right, like a little bit of a backbone so that they can better scaffold some of these that they have about the world onto what they're seeing out there in the culture. So is that people who have a psychology undergraduate degrees, and probably to some extent, is it going to be movie lovers, certainly? But anybody who's thought in any way about how the movies might or might not reflect their
人类思维的运作方式、人们相互交往的方式有很好的想法。但他们肯定没有科学依据来支持其中一些观点，而对另一些观点则没有。所以我认为我们的工作就像是，看，我们试图给人们一点基础，就像一点骨架，这样他们就可以更好地将他们对世界的看法与他们在文化中看到的东西联系起来。所以，受众是那些拥有心理学本科学位的人，可能在某种程度上，也会是电影爱好者，当然了？但任何以某种方式思考过电影可能如何反映或不反映他们
own romantic experiences, you know, we think we have something to offer these folks. Well, speaking of that reflection, overall, do you find that most romantic comedies are doing a good job reflecting how we relationships work, or are they more fantasy than reality? I love the question. And, you know, one thing that's always tempting as a, you know, as a rigorous social scientist is to be a little bit of a buzzkill, is to, you know, talk about the myths and look, it is not hard to find them. these, you know, tropes that you see and all of these rom-coms, many of them are false. One of the things that's embedded in our show, like every episode of Love Factually has a structure. Almost every episode of Love Factually is about a specific movie and there's a structure that we adopt. And one of the things that we decided early has been one of the things that has made it so fun to do the show is we have one section, one major section of every episode that's, what does the movie get right? And this is the sort of thing that forces us not to stand from on high and like throw darts at
自己的浪漫经历的人，你知道，我们认为我们能为这些人提供一些东西。嗯，说到这种反映，总的来说，你认为大多数浪漫喜剧在反映我们关系运作方式方面做得好吗，还是它们更多是幻想而非现实？我喜欢这个问题。而且，你知道，作为一个严谨的社会科学家，总是很想做一个“扫兴的人”，去谈论那些误区，看，找到它们并不难。这些你在所有浪漫喜剧中看到的套路，很多都是错误的。我们节目中嵌入的一件事，比如《事实上的爱情》的每一集都有一个结构。几乎每一集《事实上的爱情》都是关于一部特定的电影，我们采用了一种结构。我们很早就决定的一件事，也是让做这个节目变得如此有趣的原因之一，就是我们每一集都有一个主要部分，即：这部电影有哪些是正确的？这是一种强迫我们不站在高处对
Ryan Gosling. Right? We get to say like, okay, so here's a movie. It's a rom-com. Like, what are the ideas that align well with what the scientific evidence suggests is how relationships really work? And then we have a section that's right after that. That's all right.
瑞恩·高斯林指手画脚的方式。对吧？我们可以说，好吧，这是一部电影。这是一部浪漫喜剧。那么，哪些观点与科学证据所暗示的关系运作方式相吻合呢？然后我们紧接着有一个部分。那就是，好吧。
Well, what misconceptions are in the movie or what could the movie have done a little better? And so if we have to answer the question, like in general, are, you know, rom-coms doing a service or a disservice to society, I don't think I have an easy answer to that because a lot of the ideas are, in fact, good representations of how a couple learns over time what each other's patterns are and how they develop unique language that they refer back to later. Like lots of rom-coms are great at that. And yet they lean into a lot of tropes that like some people are datable and some people aren't datable. And so by and large, this genre is doing some real service to the well-being of society in terms of the message it's sending and some real disservice to society in terms of the messages they're sending. And I think the key thing is that every movie's got both of these in it. It's very rare that, you know, when we sit down to record and we compare notes, we try not to compare notes until. just before we're starting to record.
那么，电影中存在哪些误解，或者电影本可以做得更好一点的地方是什么？所以，如果我们必须回答这个问题，比如总的来说，浪漫喜剧是对社会有益还是有害，我想我没有一个简单的答案，因为很多观点实际上是对伴侣如何随着时间推移了解彼此的模式，以及他们如何发展出后来引用的独特语言的良好表现。很多浪漫喜剧在这方面做得很好。然而，它们倾向于很多套路，比如有些人是可以约会的，有些人是不可约会的。所以总的来说，这个类型在它传递的信息方面对社会的福祉做了一些真正的贡献，而在它们传递的信息方面也对社会造成了一些真正的损害。我认为关键在于每部电影都包含这两者。很少有这种情况，你知道，当我们坐下来录音并交流意见时，我们尽量在录音前才交流。
And so it's very rare that I'm like, dude, I have nothing in the gets right section. I hope you have something here. Because most of the movies, you can pick out things that are correct or useful or at least dancing around something that's correct and useful. And same thing, I would say maybe,
所以很少有我像说，伙计，我在“正确之处”部分什么都没有。我希望你这里有一些东西。因为大多数电影，你都可以挑出一些正确或有用，或者至少是在围绕着正确和有用的东西打转的内容。同样的事情，我会说也许，
especially when we cover some of the beloved classics, I think maybe it was like Brokeback Mountain. I can't remember now. But when we sat down, we're like, I don't think this movie gets, say anything wrong. What are we going to talk about? So you feel like you're grasping at things. But for the most part, there's a mix. And that's kind of what makes this exciting. How do you pick the films that you're going to talk about? You know, we pull from a few different
特别是当我们涵盖一些深受喜爱的经典作品时，我想也许是像《断背山》这样的。我现在记不清了。但当我们坐下来时，我们想，我不认为这部电影有什么地方是错的。我们要谈论什么呢？所以你会觉得你在抓耳挠腮。但在大多数情况下，这是一个混合体。这正是让它令人兴奋的原因。你们是如何挑选要谈论的电影的？你知道，我们从几个不同的
sources. Look, we try to pick movies that we think people have seen and or will remember fondly. we haven't gone back yet more than a few decades. I do expect we'll go further back in time eventually and pick off some of the old grates. But other than that, like honestly, we're just trying to keep us, you know, a mix of tones. Like we'll do some really thoughtful, pensive pieces.
来源中挑选。看，我们尽量挑选我们认为人们看过和/或会怀念的电影。我们还没有回顾超过几十年的电影。我确实预计我们最终会回溯更久远的时间，挑选一些老经典。但除此之外，老实说，我们只是试图保持一种语调的混合。比如我们会做一些非常深思熟虑、沉思的作品。
I mean, I just mentioned Brokeback Mountain. But we also try to get the goofy romantic comedies. Like, you know, we did 27 dresses not that long ago. So we really do try to mix it up. You know, we even covered the materialists recently, which is in theaters now. That was actually one of the first times that we attempted that. That's a little tricky because, you know, we like to get audio in there, and that was a little challenging. But we just try to vary up the styles, vary up the genres with the hope that, hey, people are going to find a few things that they like, and, you know, they can start with those episodes.
我的意思是，我刚才提到了《断背山》。但我们也尝试加入那些傻乎乎的浪漫喜剧。比如，你知道，我们不久前做了《27套礼服》。所以我们确实尝试混合搭配。你知道，我们甚至最近涵盖了《物质主义者》，现在正在影院上映。那实际上是我们第一次尝试这样做。这有点棘手，因为，你知道，我们喜欢在里面加入音频，这有点挑战性。但我们只是尝试改变风格，改变类型，希望人们能找到一些他们喜欢的东西，然后，你知道，他们可以从那些剧集开始。
So your first episode was about when Harry met Sally. Let's start there. Is Harry's and Sally's love, hate, friendship, relationship, dynamic, realistic. Whatever it is. Yeah. Does this movie get any of it right? Yeah. I mean, this movie has timeless insights into the nature of relationships.
所以你们的第一集是关于《当哈利遇到莎莉》。让我们从那里开始。哈利和莎莉的爱恨交织的友谊关系动态是现实的吗？无论它是什么。是的。这部电影有任何正确的地方吗？是的。我的意思是，这部电影对关系的本质有永恒的见解。
One of the things that we talked about on that episode is the friends to lovers' pathway. This is one of the ideas in the relationship space in relationship science that talks about, well, how do relationships start? And a lot of the rom-coms, I think, get this, if not wrong, they work with the improbable or less likely case where it's like a meat cute and they eyed each other across the room and fell in love. Of course, that does happen. But the much more typical case, even today, even in the era of online dating, is that somebody emerges from your existing social, million. you. And then over time, you're like, huh, there's some interest here. And Harry and Sally are sort of ideal exemplars of this idea that, look, they disliked each other at first, five years passed, then they had another weird interaction, another five years passed. And then they were
我们在那一集中谈论的一件事是“从朋友到恋人”的路径。这是关系领域、关系科学中的观点之一，讨论的是，嗯，关系是如何开始的？我认为很多浪漫喜剧，如果不是搞错了，它们处理的是不太可能或可能性较小的情况，比如浪漫邂逅，他们隔着房间对视一眼就坠入爱河。当然，这种情况确实会发生。但即使在今天，即使在在线约会时代，更典型的情况是，某人从你现有的社交圈中脱颖而出。然后随着时间的推移，你会想，嗯，这里有一些兴趣。哈利和莎莉是这种观点的理想典范，看，他们起初互相讨厌，五年过去了，然后他们有了另一次奇怪的互动，又过了五年。然后他们
like buddies for a while. And then it was like, whoa, there's something more here. And yeah, that's a beautiful thing to illustrate on screen and very well aligned with how a lot of relationships really starting. One of the things about that movie that I think is absolutely fascinating with respect to this question is that our memories of that movie, our collective memories of that movie, I think, don't exactly match the science because what a lot of people remember is the lesson, ah, men and women can't be friends, which I would say, no, the science debunks that just fine. But that's not actually what happens.
有一段时间是哥们儿。然后就像，哇，这里有更多的东西。是的，在银幕上展示这一点是一件美妙的事情，并且与许多关系真正开始的方式非常吻合。关于那部电影，我认为在这一问题上绝对令人着迷的一点是，我们对那部电影的记忆，我们对那部电影的集体记忆，我认为并不完全符合科学，因为很多人记住的教训是，“啊，男人和女人不能做朋友”，我会说，不，科学完全反驳了这一点。但那实际上并不是发生的事情。
They are friends in the movie. They are friends for years before the romantic stuff really. starts to kick in. And I think that's one of the, one of these interesting cases and why the movies are so interesting to analyze, because sometimes what the movies get wrong is not what's literally on the page, but the way that it lingered in the culture kind of spun things in an odd direction. And so that's things that we try to pull on too, to try to say, hey, you know, if we were watching this movie today, I think we'd say this gets it pretty right. It's our memories of the thing that got it wrong. So is your goal eventually to have
他们在电影里是朋友。在浪漫的事情真正开始之前，他们做了多年的朋友。我认为这是那些有趣的案例之一，也是为什么电影如此值得分析的原因，因为有时电影搞错的不是字面上的内容，而是它在文化中留下的方式，以一种奇怪的方向扭曲了事情。所以这些也是我们试图挖掘的东西，试图说，嘿，你知道，如果我们今天看这部电影，我想我们会说这反映得相当准确。是我们对它的记忆搞错了。所以你们的目标最终是
have a gig in Hollywood where you're advising scriptwriters? Funny. What about you? You want it? I don't know. I never actually thought about it. I think it's a joke question. I think it'd be fun.
在好莱坞找一份工作，为编剧提供建议吗？有趣。你呢？你想吗？我不知道。我从来没想过。我觉得这是一个玩笑问题。我觉得会很有趣。
It might be fun to, you know, consult with some of these A-list screenwriters, directors, actors, and so forth. My guess is that, Paul, you and I might not have the best instincts for what necessarily makes a good movie. We're probably better at critiquing. Yeah, but you know what's interesting. And again, why I love returning to the movies for these things is, look, what the movies do that the science doesn't do as well is it captures the specifics and the particulars that make different relationships feel lived in. And, right, I mean, that's these writers' job.
咨询一些一线编剧、导演、演员等等可能会很有趣。我的猜测是，保罗，你和我可能没有最好的直觉来判断什么必然会成就一部好电影。我们可能更擅长批评。是的，但你知道有趣的是什么吗。再次强调，为什么我喜欢回到电影中寻找这些东西，看，电影所做的科学做得不那么好的地方是，它捕捉到了使不同关系感觉“有生活气息”的细节和具体内容。而且，对吧，我的意思是，那是这些作家的工作。
That's the director's job. That's the actor's job is to make it feel alive like this is something you've encountered something you might experience yourself. And look, oftentimes in the science, we're in the business of describing. overall trends, okay? What happens on average? But I will say a lot of relationships research is trying to move
那是导演的工作。那是演员的工作，就是让它感觉鲜活，就像这是你遇到过的、你可能自己经历过的事情。看，通常在科学中，我们从事的是描述整体趋势的工作，好吧？平均而言会发生什么？但我不得不说，很多关系研究正试图朝着
in this direction of trying to capture more of the particulars, more of the idiosyncrasies of particular relationships. You can point to a little bit of like qualitative stuff is starting to become a little bit more in vogue now. But there are like different
这个方向发展，试图捕捉更多细节，更多特定关系的特质。你可以指出一点点定性研究现在开始变得更流行了。但有不同的
ways that like we're trying to do as good a job of capturing what feels real about relationships, you know, trying to catch up to what the movies are doing. Are there any particular movies that you feel really most accurately depict how relationships work in the real world? One of the things that we've done in the show is at the end of each episode, we get to be film critics, and we give a number of stars from one to five, like, how good is the movie, according to Paul Heaswick, or according to Eli Finkel, in the standard film critic way. But at Paul's insight, we do a second thing, which is we offer a rating called the Rusbolt, R-U-S-U-L-T. It's named after my advisor and one of the really founding mothers of relationship science, a woman in Carol Rusbolt. And what we do with that is evaluate from one to five Rust Bolt's, like how well aligned were the messages in the film with the scientific evidence base as far as it exists?
方式，我们正试图在捕捉关系的真实感方面做得一样好，试图赶上电影正在做的事情。有没有哪部电影你觉得最准确地描绘了现实世界中关系的运作方式？我们在节目中所做的一件事是，在每一集的结尾，我们都会成为影评人，我们给出一到五颗星，比如，根据保罗·伊斯特威克或伊莱·芬克尔的观点，这部电影有多好，以标准的影评人方式。但在保罗的建议下，我们做了第二件事，就是我们提供了一个名为“鲁斯博尔特”（Rusbolt）的评分，R-U-S-U-L-T。它是以我的导师、关系科学的奠基之母之一卡罗尔·鲁斯博尔特（Carol Rusbolt）的名字命名的。我们用它来评估一到五颗“鲁斯博尔特”，即电影中的信息与现有的科学证据基础的吻合程度如何？
I bring that up because, Paul, I haven't kept formal tabs on this, but we've had a whole bunch that got five rust bolts. Yeah, where we both gave it five. I think it's definitely happened. I mean, La La Land was one. We really thought that that absolutely nailed the full arc of the relationship. What is it that brings people together, makes them feel like they're part of a team and working together towards their goals? And then how does that process go awry sometimes? I mean, that's really one that captured the whole arc and that one sticks with me.
我提到这一点是因为，保罗，我没有正式记录过，但我们有很多获得了五颗鲁斯博尔特的电影。是的，我们俩都给了五颗星。我想这绝对发生过。我的意思是《爱乐之城》就是一部。我们真的认为它绝对抓住了关系的完整弧线。是什么把人们聚集在一起，让他们觉得他们是一个团队，并朝着他们的目标共同努力？然后这个过程有时是如何出错的？我的意思是，那确实是一部捕捉了整个弧线的电影，那部电影一直留在我的脑海里。
I mentioned broke back a second ago. That's another one that, you know, heartbreakingly realistic. Brilliant. And there are a few others, too. Marriage story was another one that I think we were both like, oh my gosh. It's great. Yeah. You know, Kim, the La La Land example is also relevant to the issue that you were bringing up earlier
我刚才提到了《断背山》。那是另一部，你知道，令人心碎的现实。精彩。还有其他几部也是。 《婚姻故事》是另一部，我想我们俩都觉得，哦，天哪。太棒了。你知道，金，《爱乐之城》的例子也与你之前提出的问题相关，
where, you know, we talked about the science is pretty good at talk. about statistical effects, right? There's a correlation of point three between this predictor variable and this outcome variable. And that's, in a sense, the opposite of the Paul. I think you used the word, the phrase lived in experience. But La La Land does this gorgeous thing. So a lot of people have probably seen this movie. This is Ryan Gosling and Emma Stone.
你知道，我们谈到科学在谈论统计效应方面相当不错，对吧？这个预测变量和这个结果变量之间有 0.3 的相关性。从某种意义上说，这与保罗，我想你用了那个词，那个短语“有生活气息的体验”是相反的。但《爱乐之城》做了一件非常美妙的事情。所以很多人可能看过这部电影。这是瑞恩·高斯林和艾玛·斯通主演的。
And Ryan Gosling is obsessed with jazz, like classical jazz, like the old-fashioned way, the way it's supposed to be done. And, you know, he and Emma Stone are building this. relationship. And fairly early on, she says, look, I should get this out of the way. Like, I don't like jazz. Now, he has already said, Ryan Gosling's character has already said to his sister, like, don't set me up with someone I, I, you know, don't send me up with a woman who doesn't, who's not interested in jazz. We'd have nothing to talk about. And what's gorgeous. Yeah, what's gorgeous about that movie is the minute that Emma Stone says, like, I'm not into jazz. He
瑞恩·高斯林痴迷于爵士乐，那种古典爵士乐，那种老派的方式，那种它本该有的方式。而且，你知道，他和艾玛·斯通正在建立这种关系。很早的时候，她说，看，我应该先说明一下。我不喜欢爵士乐。现在，他已经说过了，瑞恩·高斯林的角色已经对他姐姐说，别给我介绍我不，你知道，别给我介绍一个对爵士乐不感兴趣的女人。我们没什么可谈的。而美妙的是，是的，那部电影美妙之处在于，当艾玛·斯通说，我不喜欢爵士乐时，他
says, wait a minute. And he says, what are you doing right now? And then they go to a jazz club. And she gets to witness jazz through his eyes. And she's thrilled with it. And that's the sort of thing. It's like, that's an interesting way of depicting this idea, that our stated preferences, the things that we think are really important to us might not be especially big predictors of what actually attracts us face to face. It turns out, Paul and I have done a lot of research on this topic. A lot of other scholars have as well. But we've never depicted it with the sort of grace and elegance of Ryan Gosling taking Emma Stone to a jazz club. And so there's a nice intersection of what does the art afford in terms of the insights and messages that it sends? And how does that
说，等一下。他说，你现在在做什么？然后他们去了一家爵士俱乐部。她得以通过他的眼睛见证爵士乐。她对此感到非常激动。这就是那种事情。这是一种描绘这种观点的有趣方式，即我们陈述的偏好，我们认为对我们非常重要的东西，可能并不是我们面对面时真正吸引我们的东西的特别大的预测指标。事实证明，保罗和我在这个话题上做了很多研究。许多其他学者也做了很多。但我们从未以瑞恩·高斯林带艾玛·斯通去爵士俱乐部那样的优雅和风度来描绘它。所以艺术在它所传达的见解和信息方面提供了什么，这是一个很好的交集。而这如何跨越这种鸿沟进行交互，比如，好吧，艺术不是科学，科学也不是艺术，但它们有这种辩证关系，我们可以在节目中拆解。做这件事是一种乐趣。电影是否给了我们关于关系应该如何运作的不切实际的想法，还是它们实际上帮助人们建立了更好的关系？我们知道吗？我想我会说，你知道，我担心的套路或观点之一是，很多浪漫电影都想以高调结束。所以你以情侣在一起或第一次在一起结束，比如克服了通往祭坛或以更稳固的方式在一起路上的小插曲，对吧？
interface across this divide of like, well, art isn't science and science isn't art, but they have this dialectic that we get to unpack on the show. It's a pleasure to do. Do movies give us an unrealistic idea of how relationships should work, or do they actually help people have better relationships? Do we know? I guess I'd say, you know, one of the tropes or one of the ideas that I would worry about is that with a lot of romantic movies, they want to end on a high note. And so you end with the couple getting together or of not getting together for the first time, like overcoming a little hiccup on the way towards, you know, being at the altar or being together in a more solidified way, right?
《27套礼服》是这样做的，你知道，我的意思是《土拨鼠之日》也是这样做的。你知道，有很多很多电影，结局是情侣最终以一种半永久的方式走到了一起。我认为这里的一个问题是，它暗示了一种“从此幸福快乐”或者我们度过了棘手的部分，从现在开始一切都会一帆风顺。而事实并非如此。数据并没有显示这一点，岩石期往往会出现。很多时候，一部快乐有趣的电影不想以那种方式让人沮丧。
27 Dresses does this, you know, I mean, Groundhog Day does this. You know, there are many, many movies where the end is sort of the couple finally coming together in a semi-permanent way. And I think one issue there is that it kind of implies happily ever after of sorts or that we got through the tricky part and everything from here is going to be smooth sailing. And that's just not actually how it works. That's not what the data show, that rocky periods often emerge. And a lot of times, a Happy Fun movie doesn't want to be a downer in that way.
所以我确实认为很容易对这些事情的弧线以及挑战所在产生误解。是的，当关系开始时经常会有挑战，但以后也会出现一些事情。我们要休息一下，回来后，我们将讨论关系误区和现实是如何在电影中反映出来的，包括《一见钟情》和灵魂伴侣的概念。你的夏天现在就开始了，在家得宝（The Home Depot）享受阵亡将士纪念日的优惠。
And so I do think it's easy to come away with the misleading understanding of the arc of these things and where the challenges lie. Yes, there are often challenges as relationships get off the ground, but there are going to be some things that come in later too. We're going to take a short break, and when we come back, we'll talk about how relationship myths and realities are reflected in the movies, including Love at First sight and the idea of soulmates. Your summer starts now with Memorial Day deals at the Home Depot.
是时候点燃夏天的户外烧烤了，Nextgrill 四炉头燃气烧烤架特价仅需 199 美元，整个季节都可以用 Hampton Bay West Grove 七件套户外餐桌椅套装招待客人，仅需 499 美元。这个阵亡将士纪念日，在家得宝享受保证低价。售完即止，价格有效期为 5 月 14 日至 5 月 27 日，仅限美国。适用排除条款。详情请见 HomeDepot.com/pricematch。你说这个地方离水边只有几步之遥。我们只是还没找到那几步。
It's time to fire up summer. cookouts with the next grill four-burner gas grill on special buy for only $199 and entertain all season with the Hampton Bay West Grove seven-piece outdoor dining set for only $499. This Memorial Day get low prices guaranteed at the Home Depot. While supplies last, price invalid May 14th or May 27th, U.S. only exclusions apply. See Home Depot.com slash price match for details. You said this place was steps from the water. We just haven't found the steps yet.
我们省了多少钱？足够了。足够去迷路了。或者你可以预订希尔顿酒店的住宿。欢迎来到你的海滨房间。离水边只有几步之遥。希尔顿大促现已开始。在 Hilton.com 或希尔顿应用程序上预订，最高可享 20% 的优惠，获得你期待的住宿。当你想要节省开支，而不是惊喜时。你住哪里很重要。希尔顿，为了这次住宿。
How much did we save? Enough. Enough to get lost. Or you could book a stay with Hilton. Welcome to your oceanfront room. Just steps from the water. The Hilton sale is on now. Book on Hilton.com or the Hilton app and save up to 20% to get the stay you expected. When you want savings, not surprises. It matters where you stay. Hilton for the stay.
让我们从好电影和快乐电影转向坏电影。你们有没有 perpetuate（延续）有害关系误区或完全搞错关系科学某些方面的例子？我想到的是《致命诱惑》，例如。嗯，我们没有在节目中做过《致命诱惑》。我的猜测是，我们不应该太担心《致命诱惑》会误导人们关于关系应该如何运作。你知道，传递错误的信息，你知道，在家里尝试这个，比如，煮兔子然后……对吧？我不认为我们会看到这种情况。我实际上认为更恶劣的问题，以及我认为让关系科学专家评论这些事情的原因是那些感觉真实、感觉直观但不准确的观点。我认为那些比《致命诱惑》这类问题更具腐蚀性。在这里，我认为，你知道，我简要提到了这个观点，你知道，有些人是 10 分，有些人是 2 分，对吧？就像我刚才斜着提到了这一点，这是人们通常觉得有吸引力的观点。这不是一个疯狂的观点，对吧？有些人，至少在第一眼看来，客观上或者至少在共识上，比其他人更好看。这些观点中有真理。
Let's turn from the good and happy movies to the bad. Do you have examples that perpetuate harmful relationship myths or get some aspect of relationship science completely wrong? And I'm thinking of fatal attraction, for example. Well, we haven't done fatal attraction on the show. My guess is that we shouldn't worry too much about fatal attraction misleading people about how relationships should work. You know, sending the wrong message, you know, try this one at home like. boil the bunny and get the nap, right? I don't think we're going to see that. I actually think the more pernicious issues and the reason why I think having people who are experts in the science of relationship
问题是，在什么程度上有些人是“抢手货”，而另一些人真的不是？你真的想避开这些人。在这里我说的不是《致命诱惑》那种人。我说的是那个长得没那么好看的家伙，对比那个看起来像瑞恩·高斯林的家伙。而且，你知道，保罗在这个领域做了很多研究。这个工作的基本教训是，当然，早期关于谁有吸引力有一点共识。那是真的。
comment on these things are the ideas that feel true, that feel intuitive but aren't accurate. Those, I think, are more corrosive than these fatal attraction issues. And here, I think, you know, I mentioned briefly this idea that, you know, some people are tens and some people are twos, right? like I mentioned that obliquely earlier, this is an idea that people generally find appealing. It's not a crazy idea, right? There are people who are, at least on first sight, objectively or at least by consensus, better looking than other people are. There's truth than these ideas.
但当我们更了解人们时，金，每个人都同意你是一个出色的伴侣，无论你的伴侣是谁，或者你不是一个很好的伴侣，无论你的伴侣是谁，这种影响是很小的。关于你作为一个伴侣有多好的共识相对较小。因为使关系成功的很大一部分是我们两个人想出如何连接在一起的方式。不是关于我是 10 分，你是 10 分，或者我们俩都是 6 分，而是关于我们共同努力创造一种关系，在这种关系中，你对我来说是 10 分，或者至少对我来说是 8 分，即使你对下一个人来说不一定是 8 分。所以那种“有一些可约会的、令人向往的人，而有些人是，你知道，你真的永远不想被困住”的套路，那比真实情况要虚假得多。是的，稍微接着说一点，看，很多电影，
The question is, to what extent are some people catches and other people really not catches? You really want to avoid these people. And here I'm not talking about the fatal attraction sorts of people. I'm talking about the guy who's not as good-looking versus the guy who looks like Ryan Gosling. And, you know, Paul has done a lot of research in this space. And the idea, the basic lesson from this work is, sure, there's a little bit of consensus early on about who's appealing. That's true.
你有好人和坏人，对吧？我的意思是，那是，你知道，人们通常想看到的，思考这个问题非常引人入胜。但是天哪，在关系中，要区分好人和坏人通常没那么容易，即使你认为，好吧，所以坏人，但这意味着他性感、迷人、诱人，但实际上，他是个麻烦。你必须度过那个部分，意识到那个好人才是应该在一起的人。但即使是那样，那也不是人们在关系技能方面在世界上排列的方式。
But as we get to know people better, to what degree is it the case, Kim, that everybody agrees that you're a spectacular partner, no matter who your partner is, or you're not a very good partner, no matter who your partner is, those effects are small. The amount of consensus about how good you are as a partner is relatively small. because most of what makes a relationship successful are the ways that the two of us figure out to connect together. Not about me being a 10 and you being a 10 or both of us being sixes, but about us working together to create relationships in which you're a 10 for me or at least an eight for me, even if you wouldn't necessarily be an aid for the next person. And so the trope that there are sort of some datable desirable people and some people that are, you know, you really wouldn't ever want to get stuck with, that's. much more false than it is true. Yeah, and just to pick up on that a little bit, look, a lot of movies,
就像，是的，有些人很迷人，有些人不迷人。但认为迷人的人是糟糕的关系艺术家的观点一点也不真实。所以，当围绕善恶建立注意力并叠加在关系上时，我认为这可能会走向一些非常奇怪的地方。在我读过的一篇采访中，你提到负面互惠的概念反映在一些浪漫喜剧中。这个术语是什么意思，哪些电影将其描绘为情节的一部分？这是，你知道，回到 70 年代或更早的关系科学中的 OG（元老级）、主要观点之一。我认为目前与约翰·戈特曼联系最紧密，我认为他可能是
you got good guys and bad guys, right? I mean, that's, you know, often what people want to see, and it's very engrossing to think about that. But boy, in relationships, it's usually not quite that easy to demarcate the good guys and the bad guys, even if you think like, okay, right, so the bad guys, but what that means is that he's sexy and charming and alluring, but really, he's trouble. And you got to get through that part and realize that the nice guy was the one to be with a lump. But even that, that's not really how people are arranged in the world in terms of their relational skills.
有史以来最广为人知的关系科学家。但很多人研究过这个。负面互惠是这样一种观点：一旦负面情绪进入我们两人之间的互动，我们就无法摆脱它。所以不仅仅是有一些负面情绪。当然，关系中会有一些负面情绪。但对于我们中的一些人，或者有时它变成了一种吸收状态，我抨击你，你抨击我。这只是这种心理上的负面循环。这是离婚的主要预测指标之一。如果你追踪人们进行互动，你录像记录他们进行互动，你说的主要问题之一是，“哦哦”，一旦负面情绪进入，我们就没有任何摆脱的方法。
Like, yes, some people are charming and some people are not. But the idea that charming people are bad relationship artists is not remotely true. So the tendency to build attention around good and evil when layered on. on relationships, I think that can go in some really weird places. In one interview I read, you mentioned that the concept of negative reciprocity is reflected in some rom-coms. What does that term mean and what films depict it as part of the plot? This is one of the, you know, OG, you know, major ideas going back to the 70s or before in relationship science. I think most associated at this point with John Gottman, who I think is probably
现在，你在浪漫喜剧中确实看到了这一点。有时你在更严肃的浪漫电影中看到它们。我们也涵盖了其中一些。所以一个毁灭性的负面互惠例子来自《美丽心灵的永恒阳光》。我见过的最伟大的电影之一，最伟大的电影之一。但你看到金·凯瑞的角色
the most widely known, you know, relationship scientists of all time. But a lot of people have studied this. And it's negative reciprocity is this idea that once negativity enters an interaction between the two of us, we can't break out of it. So it's not just that there's some negativity. Of course, relationships have some negativity. But for some of us, or sometimes it becomes like an absorbing state where I lash out at you and you lash out at me. And it's just this psychological. of negativity. And that is one of the major predictors of divorce. If you track people having an interaction, your video recording them, having an interaction, one of the major problems that you say, uh-oh, is once negativity enters, we don't have any way of extricating ourselves.
和凯特·温斯莱特的角色，他们开始吵架，有一个特别的争吵，她喝醉了回家，酒驾回家，他对此很挑剔，她取笑他，他说，你是个酒鬼吗？她说，酒鬼，你是 50 年代的人吗？
Now, you do see that in rom-coms. Sometimes you see them in the more serious romantic films. We cover some of those, too. So one devastating example of negative reciprocity comes from eternal sunshine of the spotless mind. One of the great movies that I've ever seen, one of the greatest. But you see the Jim Carrey character
他们最终只是升级了。然后在电影中，正如我想任何熟悉这部电影的人都知道的那样，他们最终从彼此的记忆中抹去了对方，因为他们对彼此太厌倦了。他们对彼此太糟糕了。但我确实认为那部电影在说明一旦负面情绪渗入，如果气候不利于“我们必须在它超过我们之前停止它”，我们可能会被关系中的负面情绪所吞噬，这方面做得非常出色。然后这就引出了关于灵魂伴侣或一见钟情的问题，这推动了许多电影情节。关系科学对这些观点有什么看法？我的意思是，这是一件真实的事情，还是只是我们都希望发生的事情？所以这个很棘手。我先从一见钟情的观点开始，因为，看，我们还没有做适当的统计分析来比较。一见钟情在电影中出现的次数与在现实生活中发生的频率相比是多少？但我的猜测是，它在电影中会被大大高估，
and the Cape Winslet character, they start having fight, and there's one fight in particular where she comes home late and she's drunk and has driven home drunk and he's critical about that and she makes fun of him and he says, what are you a Wino? And she's like, Wino, what are you from the 50s?
而在现实生活中则不然。那并不是说它不会发生。它确实会发生。我们甚至在一些关于人们随时间轨迹的数据中研究过这一点，他们报告了他们过去的关系，然后重新构建了他们在不同时间点的感受。是的，你知道，有相当一部分，我不知道，20% 的人，当他们爱上这个人时，它确实从一开始就在那里。所以它确实发生了。
And they end up just escalating And then in that movie, as I think anybody familiar with the movie knows, they end up erasing each other from each other's memories because they're just so over each other. They're so bad for each other. But I do think that film does a beautiful job of illustrating how once the negativity seeps in, if the climate isn't conducive to like, we got to stop this before it overtakes us, we can become consumed with negativity in the relationship. And then that brings me to the question of soulmates or love at first sight, which drives a lot of movies. movie plots. What does relationship science say about these ideas? I mean, is it a real thing or is it just something that we all wish could happen? So this one's tricky. I'll start with the love at first sight idea because, look, we haven't done the proper statistical analysis to compare. How many times does love at first sight appear in the movies versus how often does it happen in real life? But my guess is that it's going to be vastly overrepresented. in the movies, then in real life.
我不喜欢的是它似乎被反映为一种常态。你只需要在正确的时间出现在正确的地点，闪电就会击中。这发生在许多电影中，事情从一开始就显得很神奇。我认为这对人们来说不是一个有用的想法，因为如果你单身并且不喜欢它，你会花很多时间想，哦，我只是不够幸运吗？但你不会想到你可以对正在发生的事情拥有一些代理权的不同方式。
That's not to say it doesn't happen. It certainly does happen. We've even looked at this in some data on people's trajectories over time, where they're reporting on their past relationships, and then sort of reconstructing how they felt at various points in time. And yeah, you know, there's a solid, I don't know, 20% of people who, when they fell in love with this person, it was really there from the beginning. So it definitely happened.
现在，看，约会应用程序使这一切变得复杂，因为现在感觉我们正在约会，即使你真正做的只是每天滑动 90 分钟。那不一定算作约会。所以今天有很多复杂情况。但认为闪电会击中，你从第一刻起就会知道的想法，我不喜欢这个想法。那并不是说它从不发生，但我敢打赌，它比人们想象的要罕见得多。
What I don't love is how it seems to be reflected as a commonplace. You just got to be at the right place at the right time, and lightning is going to strike. This happens in a number of movies where things just kind of seem to be magical from the very beginning. And I think that's just not a helpful idea for people, because then if you're single and not loving it, you spend a lot of time thinking like, oh, am I just not getting lucky? But you don't think about the different ways you could have some agency over what's going on.
我认为关于这个问题值得考虑的一件事是，这里实际上有两个问题。一个是，一见钟情存在吗？有些人只是，他们见面并且他们兼容，他们永远在一起，那太棒了。第二个问题是关于人们的理论，我们所有人，不仅仅是理论家，不仅仅是专业心理学家之类的，而是普通人，我们所有人，都有关于世界如何运作的理论。你可能有一个关于兼容性是否只是发生的事情的理论，对吧？丘比特拿出他的箭，他射出它，然后你们就兼容了，或者他不射，留在箭袋里，然后你们就没有机会了。
Now, look, the dating apps have complicated all of this because now it feels like we're dating, even if what you're really doing is swiping for 90 minutes a day. That doesn't necessarily count as dating. So there are many complications today. But the idea that lightning is going to strike and you'll know it from moment one, I don't love this idea. That's not to say it never happens, but it's far rarer than people think, I would bet.
人们对他们是否采用那种世界观有一定的控制权，但这与世界上什么是真实的无关。尽管如此，它是可研究的，对吧？我们可以看看，无论世界上什么是真实的，我们可以看看人们在多大程度上确信兼容性是可以从最初的时刻检测出来的，而不是，例如，兼容性是通过随时间的努力培养出来的东西。这是两种非常不同的模型。它建立在卡罗尔·德韦克（Carol Dweck）的经典工作之上。这听起来可能像是你在关系领域熟悉的那些工作，奇特尼（Chitney），
One thing that I think is worth considering about this question is there are actually two questions in here. One is, does Love at First Site exist? And are some people just, they meet and they're compatible and they make it forever, and that's great. There's a second question of people's theories, all of us, not just theorists, not just professional psychologist or something, but regular people, all of us, have theories about how the world works. And you might have a theory about whether compatibility is just something that happens, right? Cupid takes out his arrow and he shoots it and then you're compatible or he doesn't, stays in the quiver and then you don't have a chance.
以及其他人对这个问题做了很多有趣的研究。该文献的主要结论之一是，如果你是一个真正对爱情有这种灵魂伴侣视角的人，如果它要存在，它从一开始就在那里。这在预测关系结果方面不一定好或坏，但当你遇到困难，当你在关系中发生冲突时，它真的很棘手。而当你在关系中发生冲突时，它之所以如此困难的原因是，为什么我们会发生冲突？好吧，如果你相信灵魂伴侣，你开始说，哦哦，我们可能不是命中注定的。而如果你相信兼容性不是丘比特用箭创造的东西，而是我们两个人
People have some amount of control about whether they adopt that worldview, but that's independent of what's true in the world. Nonetheless, it's studyable, right? we can look at the, whatever's true about the world, we can look at the extent to which people are convinced that compatibility is something that you can just detect from the opening moments versus, for example, compatibility is something that you cultivate through effort over time. These are two very different models. It builds on classic work from Carol Dweck. This might sound like work that you're familiar with in the relationship space, Chitney,
人们在某种程度上可以控制自己是否采纳那种世界观，但这与世界上什么是真实的无关。尽管如此，它是可以研究的，对吧？我们可以观察世界上真实存在的东西，我们可以观察人们在多大程度上相信兼容性是可以从最初的时刻就察觉到的，还是说，例如，兼容性是通过时间的努力培养出来的。这是两种截然不同的模型。这建立在卡罗尔·德韦克（Carol Dweck）的经典研究基础上。这听起来可能像是你在人际关系领域熟悉的研究，奇特尼（Chitney），
and others have done a lot of interesting research on this issue. And just one of the major conclusions from that literature is if you are somebody who really has this sort of soulmate perspective on love, that if it's going to be there, it's there right from the start. That doesn't tend to be necessarily good or bad in terms of predicting relationship outcomes, but it's really thorny when you have difficulty, when you have conflict in the relationship. And the reason why it's so difficult when you have conflict in the relationship is, why are we having conflict? Well, if you believe in soulmates, you start to say, uh-oh, we're probably not meant for each other. Whereas if you believe that compatibility isn't something that Cupid creates with an arrow, but something that the two of us
以及其他人对这个问题做了很多有趣的研究。该文献的主要结论之一是，如果你是一个真正持有这种灵魂伴侣爱情观的人，认为如果缘分存在，它从一开始就在那里。这在预测关系结果方面并不一定好或坏，但当你遇到困难，当你在关系中发生冲突时，这真的很棘手。而当你在关系中发生冲突时之所以如此困难，是因为我们为什么要发生冲突？好吧，如果你相信灵魂伴侣，你就会开始说，糟糕，我们可能不是天生一对。而如果你相信兼容性不是丘比特用箭创造的东西，而是我们两个人
cultivate together, there's nothing scary about conflict. It's an opportunity to like learn about each other and to resolve the conflict and end up in a more constructive space. And that's what the research evidence shows is that these soulmate beliefs are corrosive when things are difficult. But the fact is, most of us are going to go through a difficult stage, so it's a risky belief to hold. So there's a very convenient ending to a lot of fairy tales, which is, and then they lived happily ever after. And I'm just wondering how well or poorly movies reflect this, because if the end of the movie or the climax of the movie, let's say, is the couple get together, well, then what? if I had to guess at this point, I mean, we're 27 movies in, we've had a few bonus episodes as well, but if I had to speculate at this point, you know, let's imagine that I'm speculating what it's
共同培养，冲突并不可怕。这其实是一个了解彼此、解决冲突并最终达成更具建设性共识的机会。研究证据表明，当困难出现时，这种“灵魂伴侣”的信念具有破坏性。但事实是，我们大多数人都会经历困难阶段，所以持有这种信念是有风险的。许多童话故事都有一个非常方便的结局，那就是“从此他们过上了幸福快乐的生活”。我很好奇电影在多大程度上反映了这一点，因为如果电影的结尾或高潮是男女主角走到了一起，那么接下来呢？如果我现在要猜测的话，我们已经看了27部电影，还有几集特别节目，但如果我现在要推测的话，你知道，想象一下我正在推测
going to feel like after we've done a couple hundred of these. I think this idea might be one that troubles me the most is, you know, the general plot arc of the stereotypical rom-com, but, you know, Disney movies and so forth is, well, like, will they or won't they? And maybe there's a thing here, but then we have a big fight, but it's all a misunderstanding. And then we figure it out. And then somebody proposes to someone and usually a very gendered sort of way. And they all lived happily ever after it. And look, it's fair to say that that is a standard plot for, you know, mid-level rom-coms, let's say. I think it's a pretty bad idea. And Paul, I think you were alluding to some of this earlier,
在我们看完几百部电影后会有什么感觉。我认为这个想法可能最让我困扰，那就是刻板印象中浪漫喜剧的一般情节走向，当然还有迪士尼电影等等，就是“他们会在一起吗？还是不会？”也许中间会有一些波折，然后我们大吵一架，但那只是误会。然后我们解决了问题。接着有人向某人求婚，通常是以一种非常性别化的方式。然后他们从此过上了幸福快乐的生活。听着，公平地说，这是中等水平浪漫喜剧的标准情节。我认为这是一个很糟糕的想法。保罗，我想你之前也提到了这一点，
is it sort of implies, sure, there's some like rocky bits early, but once you figure it out, everything's going to be fine. But there's probably like 50 or 60 years ahead, I mean, depending upon how old people are when they're, you know, when they're meeting and getting married or making a proposal. And the idea that like, well, now you've worked through the tough stuff is probably a corrosive idea for people to hold. I think one movie that I happen to love that I think illustrates this idea is John Cusack and Ione's Sky and say anything. They have these misunderstandings and then they break up and then he holds the boom box over his head and plays in your eyes and they end up together. And then the very last scene, they're on the airplane and there's a little bit of turbulence and then
这似乎暗示着，虽然早期会有一些坎坷，但一旦你解决了问题，一切都会好起来。但未来可能还有50或60年的路要走，这取决于人们在相遇、结婚或求婚时的年龄。认为“现在你们已经克服了困难”的想法，对人们来说可能是一种具有破坏性的观念。我认为我碰巧喜欢的一部电影很好地说明了这一点，那就是约翰·库萨克和艾欧妮·斯凯主演的《情到深处》。他们之间有误会，然后分手了，接着他举起收音机放在头顶播放《In Your Eyes》，最后他们走到了一起。而在最后一个场景中，他们在飞机上，遇到了一点气流，然后
things like settle. And I think that maybe is supposed to be like the metaphor like, well, you've been through the bumpy stuff and now the other 60 years are going to be just fine. that's a pretty troubling idea because almost every one of us is going to have some difficulty. And if you feel like, wait a minute, I never thought this could happen. Whereas it coming from, this is a bad thing, that's going to be harder than if you're like, well, of course, we're going to have ebbs and flows and we're just going to manage them because we're grownups and conflict is going to emerge. If I could defend the say-anything version of it for a second, I think what I would note is that
事情就平息了。我认为这可能被用作一种隐喻，即“你们已经经历了颠簸，现在剩下的60年将会一切顺利”。这是一个非常令人不安的想法，因为我们几乎每个人都会遇到困难。如果你觉得“等等，我从没想过会发生这种事，这是从哪来的？这一定是件坏事”，那会比你认为“好吧，我们当然会有起起落落，我们只是要处理它们，因为我们是成年人，冲突必然会出现”要困难得多。如果我能为《情到深处》的版本辩护一下，我想指出的是
what is interesting about that one is that they are on a journey. They're taking off on a journey, and it sort of makes sense as a first chapter. Whereas the things that end with proposal or wedding, those are really the ones that make me more nervous. I mean, I like the inverse grand romantic gesture in 27 dresses where sort of she runs and, you know, does the dramatic thing to try to get him back. But that's one of these, like it ended with a wedding. and everything was all good from there that make me especially nervous. But I hear what you're saying about saying anything. So there's a stereotype that rom-coms are written to basically appeal to women, chick flicks.
那部电影有趣的地方在于他们正在踏上一段旅程。他们正在开启一段旅程，作为第一章来说这很有意义。而那些以求婚或婚礼结尾的电影，才真正让我感到不安。我的意思是，我喜欢《27套礼服》中那种反向的宏大浪漫姿态，她跑过去，做了戏剧性的事情试图挽回他。但那些以婚礼结尾，并暗示“从此一切都好”的电影才让我特别紧张。但我明白你对《情到深处》的看法。所以有一种刻板印象，认为浪漫喜剧主要是为了吸引女性，即“女性电影”。
What do your friends say about you and this podcast that you're doing about what a lot of people think of as chick flicks? I don't know the data on this exactly, but my understanding is that many of these movies are, are beloved by men and women. It kind of depends on where you put the line for what exactly is a romantic movie and what exactly is a romantic comedy and what's a romantic drama. And, you know, we just covered high fidelity too, right? That's mostly about a guy's arc. That's dude.
你的朋友们怎么评价你和这个关于许多人眼中的“女性电影”的播客？我不太清楚具体的数据，但据我了解，其中许多电影深受男性和女性的喜爱。这在很大程度上取决于你如何界定什么是浪漫电影，什么是浪漫喜剧，什么是浪漫剧情片。而且，我们刚刚讨论了《失恋排行榜》，对吧？那主要是一个男人的成长故事。那是男人的电影。
Right? So, you know, there's a lot of variability in there. I think there is a real misperception in the culture that women are the ones who care about relationships and stuff. And men, I don't know, we're like dragged into it or something. That's wrong and bad. And in fact, if anything backwards, according to some new research and synthesis out there suggesting that if anything, it's men who think about relationships more, pursue relationships more, try to get into relationships more, try to care more about maintaining their relationships, et cetera, et cetera, because we men are not so good at maintaining social support networks outside. of our primary romantic relationships.
对吧？所以，这里面有很多变数。我认为文化中存在一种真正的误解，认为女性才是关心人际关系的人，而男人，我不知道，是被迫参与其中的。这是错误且糟糕的。事实上，根据一些新的研究和综合分析，情况恰恰相反，如果说有什么不同的话，那就是男性更关注人际关系，更追求人际关系，更努力地进入人际关系，更努力地维护人际关系等等，因为我们男性在维护主要浪漫关系之外的社会支持网络方面做得并不好。
So, you know, women are a little bit better at that. So I think there are plenty of men out there who find these movies appealing and are looking to, you know, think more deeply about these things. So they're secretly crying in the theater. Oh, sure. Oh, sure. I know they're in there. I see you. I see you.
所以，女性在这方面做得稍微好一点。因此，我认为有很多男性观众觉得这些电影很有吸引力，并希望更深入地思考这些问题。所以他们是在电影院里偷偷哭泣。哦，当然。哦，当然。我知道他们在那里。我看见你们了，我看见你们了。
So a fun question. For each of you, what's your favorite romantic comedy? Okay, wait. Yeah, so if it's a romantic comedy in particular, then mine is when Harry met Sally. I would say romantic movie I'm putting before sunset above it by a hair, but romantic comedy is when Harry met Sally. I deeply love it. Gosh, there's a bunch that I love it. One of my favorites is say anything.
那么一个有趣的问题。对你们每个人来说，你们最喜欢的浪漫喜剧是什么？好吧，等等。是的，如果是特别指浪漫喜剧的话，我的是《当哈利遇上莎莉》。我会说浪漫电影的话，我把《日落之前》排在它前面一点点，但浪漫喜剧绝对是《当哈利遇上莎莉》。我非常喜欢它。天哪，我喜欢的有很多。我最喜欢的一部是《情到深处》。
I mentioned it earlier to sort of critique it, but John Cusack doing what he does, Cameron Crow, you know, early in his career doing excellent work. So I'm a big fan of that one as well. So I haven't listened to all your podcasts, but I'm pretty sure you haven't done Moonstruck. Snap out of it. When are you going to do it? We're just talking about it today.
我之前提到过它并对其进行了批评，但约翰·库萨克的表演，以及卡梅伦·克罗职业生涯早期的出色作品，让我非常喜欢那部电影。我还没有听过你们所有的播客，但我敢肯定你们还没有做过《月色撩人》。快醒醒吧。你们什么时候做那部电影？我们今天刚好在讨论它。
Yeah, right. I think we're going to do it really soon. Good. You know what's funny about that is I hadn't seen it in a while. And then maybe like a couple years ago, I think it was a little bit before we started the podcast. I watched it again, and I was like, oh, my God, he, Nick Cage was such a fox. I didn't somehow remember it or encode it properly, but that, he is a stone fox of that film.
是的，没错。我想我们很快就会做那部电影。太好了。有趣的是，我已经有一段时间没看它了。然后大概几年前，我想是在我们开始做播客之前，我又看了一遍，我当时想，天哪，尼古拉斯·凯奇当时真是太帅了。我不知怎么没记住或者没正确编码这个印象，但他在那部电影里简直帅呆了。
Yeah. All right. Well, I'm looking forward to that one. So what's next for your podcast? And what are you planning? Do you have another season coming up? What movies are you planning? We just released Pride and Prejudice pretty recently.
好的。好吧，我很期待那一期。那么你们的播客接下来要做什么？你们有什么计划吗？你们有下一季的计划吗？你们打算做哪些电影？我们最近刚刚发布了《傲慢与偏见》。
And you caught us. Moonstruck is definitely coming. And then another one that we're going to be doing soon as another personal favorite. I'm excited to revisit it. Haven't seen it in a while is 40-year-old virgin. Well, Dr. Eastwick, Dr. Finkel, thanks for joining me. This has been just a laugh riot. A lot of fun.
你们抓到我们了。《月色撩人》肯定会做。然后我们很快要做的另一部是我的另一个个人最爱。我很兴奋能重温它。我已经有一段时间没看了，那就是《四十岁的老处男》。好吧，伊斯特威克博士，芬克尔博士，感谢你们加入我。这真是一场充满欢笑的节目。非常有趣。
Thank you. Thank you so much. Thank you so much for having us. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingof psychology. Or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please follow us. and leave a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at Speaking of Psychology at APA.org. Speaking of Psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Thank you for
谢谢。非常感谢你们邀请我们。你们可以在我们的网站 speakingofpsychology 上找到《心理学谈话》之前的节目。或者在 Apple、Spotify、YouTube 或任何你们获取播客的地方收听。如果你喜欢你所听到的内容，请关注我们并留下评论。如果你对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，可以发送电子邮件至 Speaking of Psychology at APA.org。《心理学谈话》由李·韦纳曼制作。感谢你们
listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
收听。我是美国心理学会的金·米尔斯。这一集还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。